you can now relive some iconic vegas
nostalgia too that's right well circus
circus is welcoming families and
thrill-seekers back to the adventure
dome
and rocky theas is giving us a sneak
peak of all the safe fun
you can have we are inside the adventure
dome
and like every other business around the
world you've had to make your pandemic
pivot so what changes have you made
tonight
so we've put social distancing every on
all the rides you don't have to ride
with a stranger you ride with the people
that you came with
and just having fun here for spring
break
everybody's tired of being in the house
and they're out having fun
yes and of course i'm seeing everybody
with their mask on
you're encouraging people to just come
with their small family or small group
right stay in their small group
okay okay so when they do get here oh my
gosh
i'm not even on the roller coaster
i'm not even on it imagine me on it okay
i'm such a whip when it comes to rides
nowadays but let's take a walk i want to
show everybody
around the adventure dome um now
you've been doing this a long time and i
hear your offices
are inside this dome it's inside the
mountain
it shakes every time the coasters go
around what
i get i get used to it but other people
that aren't used to it they start
grabbing for the walls real fast so
they're like me
so they're like me so i understand that
there's a there's a dream team
here at the adventure norm and you're
part of it and as the vice president of
attractions here
you actually come up with the designs
for all the roller coasters and rides
we we have the owner and the president
of the property and the senior vice
president operations the engineering of
course because they have to maintain it
and then we got to pick things that are
fun
that adds to the mix and which also fits
inside the dome here too
so every ride we put in it's like
building a ship and a bottle oh my god
that's some serious engineering that you
guys are doing
and of course i understand it's it's a
dome it's a cave vibe right
so the style is really fun as well it's
it's a lot of fun
there's a lot of things going on here
that we have 25 rides and attractions
and we're planning on having um two to
three more additions and that's really
exciting
we're still coming up with uh what's
actually going to be the best fit for
the
ride mix in here so there's something
for everybody that is great something
something that has been here for so many
years but still evolving still changing
still getting better
clean safe fun that's that's our motto
and we want to continue to add to the
excitement
put in a new ride so people come back
and enjoy the park
i love it so tell everybody what your
new spring break hours are
spring break we're open 10 to midnight
and
we're excited to have everybody out and
having fun with their family and friends
okay so if there was one ride you can
get me on which one would it be
i would recommend the roller coasters or
the most popular
but we have something for everybody
carousels
ferris wheels bumper cars so it just
depends on what you're courageous enough
to do
i think bumper cars is is uh just right
for me
you can do bumper cars that's much less
i can handle but thank you so much time
this place is so cool
i'll send it back to you